نكمل واياكم مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه شكرا
لكريم هذه التغطيه المباشره لوصول رعايه
صينيين من السودان الى ميناء جده طبعا نحن
نرصد منذ حوالي الساعتين وصول هذه
الباخره التي كما ذكر الزميل هاني الصفيان
هي باخره وقود ولكنها الصصلحت واستخدمت
لنقل رعايه من مناطق الاشتباك في السودان
طبعا هم قدموا من الخرطوم الى ميناء
بورتسودان ومن هناك الى ميناء جده اعود
للزميل هاني الصفيان لنقل الصوره من هناك
هاني
نعم
اذا نواصل العربيه تواكب وتواصل تغطيتها
لعمليه الاجلاء من الرعايه الصين الذين
وصلوا للتو الى مدينه جده طبعا هؤلاء
وصلوا
ووقفت السفينه قبل 45 دقيقه تقريبا وهي
سفينه نفط او مخصصه للنفط ولكن اضطرت الى
نقل هؤلاء الرعايه بعد
مناشدتهم للحكومه الصينيه وايضا لم
يستطيعوا الوصول الى بر الامان او الى
منطقه امنه فاضطرت هذه السفينه النفطيه
الى حملهم
والذهاب بهم الى مدينه جده بعد ان سمحت
لهم السلطات السعوديه واستعانوا بالسلطات
السعوديه التي استجابت بشكل سريع بيئه
توجه الى مدينه جده
لوصولهم بسلام وامان وبعد ذلك يتم عمل
الترتيبات اللازمه
لنقلهم الى مقر اقامه مهيا وبعد ذلك يتم
ترتيبهم عفوا يتم الترتيب معهم الى يتم
الترتيب معهم مع السفاره الصينيه
لمغادرتهم الى الصين بسلام وامان عموما ما
زلنا نواكب عمليه
على كل حال هاني سنبقى نواكب معك عمليه
يعني انزال هؤلاء الركاب بعدما تم اجلائهم
من العاصمه الخرطوم طبعا وصولا الى
بورسودان ومنها الى ميناء او مطار جده
شكرا ميناء جده الاسلامي طبعا شكرا لك
هاني وسنعود اليك ضمن هذه التغطيه
ايضا ضمن حديث الوسطات اكد وزير خارجيه
جنوب السودان ان رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان اكد لرئيس جنوب السودان
موافقته على لقاء قائد قوات الدعم السريع
دجالو وايضا اوضح وزير خارجيات السودان
بان محاولات اقناع حمادي للقاء البرهان ما
زالت مستمره فلنستمع لما قاله
[موسيقى]
المكالمتين مع
الجهتين استطاع ايضا ان يعرض عليهما
خريطه عمل هي في الحقيقه تهدف الى
دعوه الجهات المعنيه بالوضع السوداني الى
طاوله الحوار
وكذلك
دعوه المجتمع الدولي الى ان يقفوا على
جانب الاتحاد الافريقي من اجل ايجاد حل
طريقي
مع استمرار المواجهات في السودان والجهود
الدوليه المبذوله لوقف اطلاق النار اعلن
البيت الابيض عن العمل مع طرفي الصراع في
السودان لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار لوقف
العنف وتامين المسارات الانسانيه مشيرا
الى ان وقف اطلاق النار في السودان مستمر
رغم بعض الخروقات بالاضافه الى عمليات
القصف العشوائي التي اسفرت عن مقتل مدنيين
او مدنيين بينهم امريكي هو الثاني حتى
الان واكد البيت الابيض على مواصله العمل
للتامين خروج كل مواطن امريكي يريد مغادره
الاراضي السودانيه
من جهتهم مشاهدينا قال المتحدث الرسمي
باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا
الوسميجال ان الاتحاد يرحب بالهدنه
الانسانيه في السودان ولكن يريد الوصول
الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
كنا نرحب بطبيعه الحال باعلان هذه الهدنه
الانسانيه في السودان بعد ايام من من
الصراع ولكن صحيح هناك اعلانات هنا هناك
لاختراقات وانتهاكات لكن نحن نريد ان نكرر
دعواتنا لنطاق المتقاتله
لجعل هذه الهدنه الانسانيه لوقت دائم
اظهرت صور متداوله على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تحركا لقوات كبيره من الجيش الى
الخرطوم وافادت مصادر هنا بان تلك القوات
تحركت من ولايات الجزيره والنيل الابيض
ونهر النيل الفن نتابع
[موسيقى]
الجمال والله
معنا مشاهدينا من اندرمان مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي سالم سابدا من هذه النقطه
التي ذكرناها الان وفي تغطيه الساعتين
الماضيتين هل يعني رصدتم تحركات لارتال
نحو وسط العاصمه للجيش السوداني
تحدث شهود عيان
السوداني ربما هي متوجهه الى مناطق التي
تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم السريع في مناطق
متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم بحسب المصادر
لكن حتى هذه اللحظه هناك مواجهات بين
الفين والاخرى في الساعه الماضيه كانت في
مناطقة من العاصمه الخرطوم يضاف اليها
كذلك بعض حركه حركه لطائرات الخطوط الجويه
السودانيه القوات الجويه السودانيه وهي
تقوم بمجموعه من العمليات في استهداف
المناطق التي تتمركز بها قوات الدعم
السريع
ايضا
يعني ظلت هذه او خلال هذا اليوم العديد من
المواجهات في مناطق متفرقه منها في مدينه
بحري مثلا في شرق النيل وكذلك في كافوري
وايضا في مدينه ام درمان في مناطق محيطه
لذاعه والتلفزيون وايضا في المهندسين وما
حولها وفي الخرطوم كذلك في اقصى جنوب
الخرطوم في الاقمار الصناعيه ايضا كانت
هناك اشتباكات عنيفه ايضا بين الجيش
السوداني والقوات الدعم السريع في الشارع
شارع الفلق
هذه مجمل الاشتباكات خلال هذا اليوم بين
الجيش
يضاف اليها ان الكثير الكثيرين تحدثوا على
ان هذه القوات جاءت لعمليه تمشيط للعاصمه
الخرطوم للقضاء على تمرض الاشياء الدعم
الصحيح
سالم مقابل رصد يعني هذه الارتال التي اتت
لدعم القوات قوات الجيش السوداني
هل ايضا اعداد من المقاتلين او من القوات
التي اتت لدعم الدعم السريع من مناطق اخرى
نعم هناك من تحدث عن هذا الامر مساله ان
هنالك يعني مجموعه من السيارات التي كانت
تريد ان تدعم قوات الدعم السريع في مناطق
متفرقه لكن ابرزها في منطقه البشير في ام
درمان في شارع
الشارع
يتجه الى سوق ليبيا غربا في هذه المنطقه
ايضا شهدت اشتباكات الان وانا اتحدث اليك
استمع
مضادات للطائرات من محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون وهي ايضا تضيع في سماء انظر ما
في هذه الطبقه نستمع اليها ونرى ونشاهد
هذه المضادات وبالتالي جديد للهدنه
يعني محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون هناك يعني
مواجهات ما زال دائره منذ بدء هذه
الاشتباكات هل تغير شيء بالفريق الذي
يسيطر على
الداخل والمحيط
شيء بشكل كبير لكن هناك طائره تحلق في ما
ام درمان نعم اسمح لي ان اشير الى هذه
العواجل التي ترد الان الجيش السوداني
للعربيه يقول لا تفاوض مع المتمردين لا في
جنوب السودان ولا في دوله اخرى اذا كانت
هذه تصريحات الجيش السوداني للعربي اعود
اليك سالم
اذا كان هذا التمشيط سينشط الان معناه ان
الهدنه التي بدات بالامس ببساطه او بواسطه
قبل امس وساطه امريكيه شارفت على النهايه
قبل ان اخذ الاجابه منك سالم اسمح لي ان
اشير مشاهدينا الى ان هذا التصريح للجيش
السوداني بان البرهان لن يسافر الى دوله
اخرى حاليا للقاء قائد التمرد وبالتالي هم
يتحدثون عن دقلو وايضا بان لا مفاوضات مع
المتمردين لا في الجنوب ولا في ولايه اخرى
ياتي ردا على تصريحات
وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان الذي قال في وقت
سابق بان رئيس
المجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان وافق على لقاء
محمد حمدان اذا هذا النفي وطبعا هناك نفي
اخر اتى ايضا عن لسان الخارجيه خارجيه
جنوب السودان
موافقه من قبل الطرفين حتى الساعه وفقد
طبعا ترحيب بالمسار السلمي ولكن ليس هناك
من مسار عملاتي يفضي الى وقف لاطلاق النار
والى هدنه بين الطرفين وطبعا الى مفاوضات
سياسيه اعود اليك سالم
كنا نتحدث عن يعني الاشتباكات التي تتحدث
عنها والتمشيط الذي تتحدث عنه التمشيط
دخول قوات جديده هل نحن امام ساعات تصعيد
مقبله
نعم هذا ايضا واضح مساله سعيد في بيانات
الجيش والتي تحدثت على انه هنالك قناصه
منتشرين في مناطق متفرقه من الخرطوم وام
درمان ربما يكون للجيش السوداني ايضا
التعامل مع هؤلاء القناصه في سعه المقبله
هي هذه الارسال التي جاءت في مناطق متفرقه
من العاصمه الخرطوم لم تبدا اشتباكات او
لم يتضح او لم
المواطنون هذه الاشتباكات بوضوح عدا اماكن
وقليله جدا حتى الان مقارنه بالاركان عدد
من المواطنين في مناطق متفرقه ربما تكون
هنالك خطه معينه يتبع الجيش السوداني في
التعامل مع مثل هذه لكن من الواضح انه
يمكن ان يقال انها الساعه القادمه
مليئه بالاحدث وبالتالي تحشيد اذا صح
التعبير يعني بانتظار ساعه الصفر اذا ما
لم تصفر اي من المفاوضات لوقف اطلاق النار
الدائم تمهيدا لحوار بين الطرفين الى اي
نتيجه شكرا لك سالم الهاشمي حدثتنا من ام
درمان مراسل العربيه
اكد مشاهدينا الجيش السوداني في تصريحات
للعربيه كما تابعنا معكم في العواجل قبل
قليل انه لا تفاوض مع المتبردين حسب حسب
وصف طبعا الجيش السوداني لا في جنوب
السودان ولا في اي دوله اخرى وان البرهان
لن يسافر الى دوله اخرى للقاء احمد وذلك
ردا على تصريحات وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان
في الاثناء اعلن الجيش السوداني التصدي
لهجوم لقوات الدعم السريع على مقر القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم وقال
الجيش انه كبد قوات الدعم السريع خسائر
فادحه بحسب البيان واتهم الجيش قوات الدعم
السريع بمواصله خرق الهدنه المعلنه
[تصفيق]
في رئاسه الشرطه
رئاسه شرطه الولايه ودينا المواطنين
ماشيين ماشيين قال لهم
يمشيطه المحليه
شرطه المحليه للمواطنين العاديين دارين
يمشوا ياخذوا لهم اسلحه من شرطه المحليه
لانه ما في قوه يعني تحميم اي زول امشي
يحمي نفسه
حملت قوات الدعم السريع المجتمع الدولي
مسؤوليات المسؤوليات تجاه خرق الهدنه من
قبل قيادات الجيش السوداني مشيره الا ان
عدم التزام قيادات الجيش بالهدنه تؤكد
تعدد مراكز القرار داخل الجيش كما اتهمت
قوات الدعم السريع قوات من الجيش بمهاجمه
مواقعها بمحيط القصر الجمهوري وارض
المعسكرات وسوبا في وقت واحد
من جهاته دعا وزير الماليه السودانيه
وزعيم حركه العدل والمساواه جبريل ابراهيم
دعا الشباب الى تشكيل لجنه شعبيه لحمايه
المدن المتاثره بالحرب وقال جبريل ابراهيم
في تغريدات على حسابها على تويتر ان الوضع
في مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور
يتسم بالفوضى العارمه مشددا على ضروره
التحرك لايقاف الماساه هناك على حد تعبيره
ما موقف اطراف الصراع في السودان من خروج
رموز نظام البشير من السجن
الجيش السوداني سلطه اداره السجون خارج
نطاق اختصاصنا وتحت مسؤوليه وزاره
الداخليه
الدعم السريع لا سيطره لدينا على السجون
في السودان وهذه مسؤوليه الشرطه
الميليشيات المتمرده اجبرت شرطه السجون
على اطلاق سراح النزلاء قيادات المواليه
للبشير في الجيش هي المسؤوله عن اطلاق
سراحه
اداره سجن كوبر اطلقت سراح نزلائه بسبب
انقطاع المياه والكهرباء والاعاشه خروج
قيادات البشير من سجن كوبر صدمه وانتكاسه
للشعب السوداني نحن غير معنيين باي بيانات
من اي جماعه او افراد خرجوا من السجون
مغادره قيادات النظام البشير للسجن امر
متوقع وبعضهم مطلوبون دوليا
وفي مسلسل المعاناه للسودانيين المدنيين
يشكون من رصاص الدوشكا الروسي ويقولون انه
يخترق جدران المنازل ويصيبهم باصابات
بالغه
رشاش الدوشكا الروسي صمم في الثلاثينات من
القرن الماضي
السودان من الدول التي تستخدم هذا الرشاش
بكثره
طلقته كبيره الحجم من عيار 12.7 ملم
يصل مدا الرمل الى ثلاثه الاف وخمائه متر
في الاصل هو رشاش ثقيل مضاد للطائرات
يمكن استخدامه ضد المدرعات الخفيفه
والاليات العسكريه
اذا تم استخدامه في المناطق المدنيه سيؤدي
الى اضرار مروعه
دعا من العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريش الاطراف المتصارعه في السودان الى
وقف القتال في البلاد اشددا على ان القتال
لن يكون حلا للصراع بين القوتين غوتريس
دعا قاده السوداء لجعل مصالح شعبهم اولويه
وان يقوموا باسكات اسلحتهم فورا
هذا وكانت بريطانيا عبرت عن قلقها ازاء
تقارير التي تفيد بان الطرفين اخفق مره
اخرى بالوفاء في التزاماتهما حول الهدنه
ودعت قوات الجيش والدعم السريع الى وقف
دائم لاطلاق نار وانهاء العنف اضافه الى
السماح بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه وضمان
حمايه المدنيين والعاملين في المجال
الانساني والطبي
وفي اخر تطورات عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
قال مراسل العربيه ان نحو سبع طائرات
عسكريه تصل يوميا الى بورسودان للاجلاء
بتنسيق مع الجيش هذا ووصلت احدى طائرات
الاجلاء الى بيروت بمساعده السعوديه محمله
32 شخصا كما تمر عمليات الاجلاء الى ليبيا
عبر ثلاث مراحل بريه وجويه وبحريه تبدا
بالانتقال بالحافلات الى بورتسودان ثم الى
ميناء جده وصولا الى المحطه الاخيره في
طرابلس هذا واستقبل مطار
معيتقيه الدوري 105 من افراد الجاليه
الليبيه في السودان بعد اجلائهم واكدت
الجزائر ان 13 فلسطينيا واكثر من عشرينا
وعددا اخر من الرعايه
وبالخرطوم قدموا من مطار بورسودان
جاؤوها بحثا عن فرص جديده وهاهم يغادرونها
للنجاه بحياتهم نحو عشره الاف شخص من
خمسين دوله حول العالم تم اجلائهم حتى
الان منهم 2250 من جنسيات مختلفه نقل بحرا
من ميناء بورتسودان الى بناء جده في
السعوديه
اكثر من 1500 مواطن مصري والمئات من
المواطنين العرب عاشوا السفر الجلاء
الاصعب اكثر من الف كيلو متر بحافلات
نقلتهم الى الحدود المصريه
خشم الباب
ونهب مسلح بصوره عشوائيه احنا
وبيوتنا مش معروف عن القهوه
عشان دي عبره لحد السنكاتها اخذنا يومين
وسجلنا هنا والله البحريه السعوديه بارك
الله فيهم
400 فرنسي ومئه الماني وغيرهم من الدول
الاجنبيه تنقل جوا من مطار عسكري قرب
الخرطوم الى مطار جيبوتي بعثه دبلوماسيه
امريكيه وروسيه واسيويه وجدت هي الاخرى
السبيلا للنجاه من حرب السودان معظم هؤلاء
النازحين كانوا محركا نهضه ماموله في
السودان اطباء ومهندسون ومعلمون قادوا
عجله تنميه تعصرت
فقهيدوا خارج الحدود لكن ماذا عن
السودانيين الراغبين في النجاه بحياتهم
لقد وقعوا فريسه تجار
الحربات عامه في التذاكر
حتى
يقول هؤلاء الشبان ان تذكره الحافله وصلت
الى 350 دولار سوق حرب سوداء بدات تلوح في
الافق نشاهد لعائلات نزحت الى تشاد بحثا
عن امن وغذاء تذكر بالسنوات مجاعه وجفاف
ولكن هذه المره السبب البشر وليس قله
المطر
يعني تذكره الصباح بسعر والنسب بسعر الباص
لكن
منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل انفجرت الاوضاع
داخل السودان بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
مناطق جغرافيه متباعده في هذا البلد
الشاسع شمالا مشاهدينا في المراوي في
الوسط في الخرطوم وفي الغرب في دارفور
الان في الاسبوع الثاني من هذه الاشتباكات
يبدو بان نقاط ونطاق هذه المواجهه الحاميه
بين الطرفين اصبحت اكثر تركيزا داخل
العاصمه الخرطوم اذا هذه العاصمه التي
يقال عنها مثلثه لماذا لانها تتكون من
ثلاث تجمعات سكانيه كما نتابع هنا الخرطوم
بحري ام درمان والخرطوم مدينه الخرطوم
جنوبا يمكن لنا ان نقول ان معظم
الاشتباكات الدائره الان في مدينه الخرطوم
الجنوبيه تنحصر حول نقطتين اساسيتين كما
نشاهد هنا قياده القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني والمطار حول المطار هنا يقول
الجيش السوداني بان قوات الدعم السريع
تسيطر على المطر اما قياده الجيش القياده
العامه فيسعى الطرفان الان للسيطره عليها
لماذا لان هذه النقطه تعتبر استراتيجيه
بمسار هذا النزاع الدائر بين الطرفين اذا
تنحصر المواجهه حول المطار وحول القياده
العامه حيث توجد اشتباكات حاميه بين قوات
الجيش والدعم السريع في الخارج اما النقطه
الثالثه
للاشتباكات فهي طبعا شرق المطار تقع
اشتباكات في حي الرياض كما نشاهد هنا كما
تقع اشتباكات ايضا في منطقه القصر
الجمهوري غربي المطار واشتباكات اخرى في
حي الصحافه وفي حي جبره وفي الكلا جنوب
غرب المطار اذا هذه خارطه الاشتباكات بهذه
النقطه اما مشاهدينا في ام درمان في ام
درمان غربي النيل توجد اشتباكات متفرقه
بين الطرفين اذا
تحديدا الاشتباكات تنحصر هنا حول مقر
الاذاعه والتلفزيون كما نشاهد هنا بهذه
الاشتباكات الدائره بين الطرفين هنا قوات
الدعم السريع تقول بانها تسيطر على هذه
النقطه وتسيطر على مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون بينما يسيطر الجيش على محتوى
البث عبر محطه خارجيه اما النقطه الخامسه
فهي في الخرطوم بحري الوضع هنا هادئ قليلا
واهدئ طبعا من الخرطوم لكنه يبقى محتدما
وقبل يومين كما تابعنا خرج سجناء من هذه
النقطه تحديدا
هي سجن كوبر والذي يعتبر من اشهر السجون
واكبر السجون في الخرطوم بحري بعدما قالت
الشرطه انها اضطرت لفعل ذلك بسبب انقطاع
خدمات المياه والكهرباء التي طبعا انقطعت
منذ بدا هذه الاشتباكات بين قوات الدعم
السريع وبين الجيش السوداني اذا مشاهدينا
كانت هذه ابرز نقاط المواجهه بين الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني التي كما قلنا
انها تنحصر الان في داخل العاصمه بمحيط
القياده العامه القصر الجمهوري ونقاط اخرى
كما فصلها
احنا ما حنطلع من بيوتنا من بيوتنا ما
حنطلع احنا هنموت في بيوتنا الموت واحد
احنا اولادنا يقوموا من الصباح عشان
يجيبوا لنا مويه لغايه بالليل
حد وين يا
اخي خاف
وا الله خافوا الله فينا لا حول ولا قوه
الا بالله الزول يدعيكم يقول فيكم شنو
الامه كلها بتدعي فيكم
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من لندن عبر الهاتف
الطيب الزين الصحافه السوداني استاذ يعني
اليوم الوضع على الارض يمكن وصفه بانه
ستاتيكو جامد ما عرفت قوات جديده تدخل الى
العاصمه من الطرفين هل يمكن ان نتحدث عن
تغيير بهذا الاستاتيكول جامد عبر ارض
المعارك بظل رفض الطرفان لاي مفاوضات او
هدنه حقيقيه والانتقال الى مسار السياسي
الان
هناك طبعا
يعني تحركات
دعم
الطرفين او المتصارعين في الخرطوم وكل جهه
بتحاول ان تدعم
الطرف الذي ترى انه يمثل يمثلها في هذه
الحرب رغم ان الحرب لا تمثل احدا وانما في
الاراده الشر يعني
ذكرتي او كما ذكرت تقرير انه الاوضاع
السودان جامده نظرا يعني
المعارك هي تدور ما في هدف معين للطرفين
يعني في الارض نستطيع من خلال نقول انه
اذا هذا الطرف حصل على هذا الموقع يعني
يحسم الامور لانه السودان بلد واسع
المساحه العمليات المسرح متحرك
تسيطر على مكان الجيش
يدخل في منطقه
ينتزع المنطقه وهكذا بنكرر
حتى الساعه على ما يبدو ان طرفي النزاع
يعني غير راضيين او غير منفتحين لاي
مبادره حوار جديه كما تابعنا يعني ما قاله
وزير خارجيه السودان عاد ونفاهه الجيش
وبالتالي هل يمكن الحديث بان لا حوار ولا
مسار سلمي بين الطرفين قبل تغيير بموازين
القوى على الارض
انا قبل فتره يعني تحدثت عن هذا الموضوع
وابتدت انه
البرهان والذين يقفون معه لا يرغبون
في حل للمشكله بل يريدون المعرفه
عبر الحرب لماذا لانهم يؤمنون بان الدوله
البلد نحو الهاويه
يصبح الامر صعب على على الدوله على
المجتمع السوداني ان يملئ اطرافه
هذه المعركه معركه قصيره
للشعب السوداني معركه يعني الشعب السوداني
لا يستفيد من ورائها بل الارواح والدماغ
ويفقد الخدمات بالنسبه للشعب هي ليست
معركه الشعب ولا الجيش السوداني وان هي
معركه اخوان المسلمين الذين لا يريدون او
نحن في السودان
هؤلاء لا يريدون للشعب السوداني الذي
ضد نظام عمر البشير ثلاثه قوت
طيب تعميق ازمه الشعب السوداني اليوم على
كافه المستويات نحن نتحدث عن مجتمع اصلا
هو ماذوم اقتصاديا اجتماعيا على كافه
الصعد بظل يعني الاقتتال الداخلي الذي هد
عبر اتفاقيات التي تم الاتفاق عليها
بالفترات السابقه وكان يؤمل بان يكون هناك
يعني مرحله انتقاليه حقيقيه عبر المسار
مسار الاليه الثلاثيه والرباعيه والمسار
العمليات الديمقراطيه اليوم تعميق ازمه
المجتمع السوداني على المستوى الاجتماعي
والسياسي الى اي مدى تؤخر الحل بالنسبه
للسودان
حتى وان ذهب الاطراف بعد فتره من الزمن
الى نوع من الحوار مع العلم يعني بانه
مستبعد
مستبعده انا في تقديري زي ما ذكرت لك انه
العقليه الحاكمه في الخرطوم او الان بظل
وجود البرهان ومن يدعمون ويجيون الحرب لا
يؤمنون بان هذه الدوله
حقل الجميع حقل جميعا يعيشوا فيها
ظل نظام مدني ديموقراطي على دوله المواطنه
التي تكفل الحقوق والواجبات
فهيم
ترى في ذهني
ان هذه الدوله
استباح بالنسبه له ولذلك يمارسون هذا
المنطق غير موجود ايضا عند يعني الطرف
الاخر بحسب بحسب هذا الطرف بحسب الجيش
يعني ايضا يقول بان الطرف الاخر لا يريد
دوله حقيقيه وهو عباره عن ميليشيا وايضا
يعني البعض الثالث يحمل حتى الاطراف
المدنيه جزء من المسؤوليه بسبب الانقسامات
الداخليه يعني صوره معقده اليوم
يعني تلقي بالمسؤوليه على كافه الاطراف
السودانيه ابقى معنا لو سمحت معنى متحدث
مشاهدينا باسم وزاره الصحه محمد ابراهيم
عبد الرحمن للحديث عن الواقع الانساني
هناك بعدما تعمقت الازمه الانسانيه
والصحيه تحديدا استاذ دكتور محمد يعني
اليوم هناك نقص على كافه
المستويات الطبيه المستشفيات خارج الخدمه
جثث في الشوارع كيف يمكن وصف الوضع داخل
الخرطوم
بسم الله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
نترحم اولا على
الذين فاتت ارواحهم الى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
ونتمنى من الله عاجل الشفاء للجرحى وعبركم
نشيد بالغطاء الصحي العريض الذي مازال
يقدم الخدمات تحت هذه الظروف
عدد المستشفيات العامله نحن في الغرفه
المركزيه وزاره الصحه ولايه الخرطوم هي
جزء من الغرفه المركزيه لاداره الازمه
الاتحاديه الغرفه الاتحاديه هذه المعلومات
معلومات مثل السجلات وزاره الصحه معلومات
مؤكده وموثقه هذه المعلومات نعتمد عليها
في قراءه الواقع والمعامله معه والتنبؤ
بمالات المستقبل
عدد المسيفات العامله الان بالحد الادنى
من القوى العامله هي 100 مستشفى تقدم
الخدمات على مستوى الطاري وشفا الطاري
من مجمل 134 مستشفى في ولايه الخرطوم على
القطاعين الغطاء الحكومي والقطاع الخف 34
مستشفى هي خارج الخدمه نسبه لوجود هذه
المستشفيات في الاماكن التي مازال
الاشتباك حولها
مجمل عدد الاصابات من تاريخ
15/4 وحتى اليوم
2,159 حاله اصابه منها 1108 حاله في
مستشفيات الحكوميه
1041 في مشاهده قطاع الخاص المجمل عدد
الوفيات الموثقه عندنا
بشهادات وفاء او تحويل الى المشارح 155
حاله 51 حاله وفاه في مسيفرات القطاع
العام و14 حاله القطاع الخاص هذه حالات
الوفيات اما لتاكيد الوفاء او حصلت الوفاء
اثناء تقديم الخدمات الصحيه عدد مراكز
الغيل الكلى التي تقدم غسيل الكل الطاري
والدائم لعدد 4000 مريض 30 مركز بسعه
6300 مريض بسعه 6 600 مكنه الساعه
التشغيليه لسته 1800 مريض عدد المرضى
الموجودين المسجلين في وزاره الصحه 4100
غسيل الكلى خدمات مجانيه
عدد المراكز العامله من مجمل 30 ماركه سي
24 مركز السته مراكز الاخرى تقع ضمن
المستشفيات التي تم تفريغها لعدم الامان
الخدمات الطوارئ في الغطائين العام
والخاصيه خدمات مجانيه وخدمات غسيل الكيلو
خدمات مجانيه بالنسبه للمراكز الصحيه
المرجعيه التي
خصصناها لمراجعه الحالات المزمنه التي لم
تتمكن من متابعه حالاتها في المستشفيات
البعيده
الان تتابع حالاتها في مركز في مستشفيات
مركزيه
مراكز مرجعيه مراكز صحيه مرجعيه تقدم
الخدمه على مستوى
الاختصاص طب الاسره والتخصصات الاساسيه
الاربعه هذه المراكز 51 مركز من مجمل 81
مركز موزعه في الكتله السكانيه على
السبع محليات التي تكون ولا تخصص
دكتور محمد يعني بموازات هذه الصوره
هل هناك
استيلاء او او يعني بالمستشفيات التي قلت
انها خارج الخدمه هل هناك استلاء لبعض
القوات المسلحه عليها
لم يوجد حفر لذلك هذه المستشفيات خطره تم
تفريغها فقط موجود فيها قوات الامن الخاص
بوزاره الصحه تم تفريغها تماما من المرضى
ومن الكوادر مقدمات الخدمه والان هي تفرز
بافراد الامن الذين ينتمون الى وزاره
وزاره الصحه على مستوى
الطاقم الطبي ببدايه هذه الازمه مع اشتداد
الاشتباكات كان هناك نقص على مستوى
الطواقم الطبيه هل اليوم الطاقم كافيه
للمئه مستشفى التي تحدثت عنها
تم استغلال فتره الهدنه وتم
تبديل الطواقيم التي كانت تعمل في المئه
مستشفى كما ذكرت لك 100 مستشفى تعمل بالحد
الادنى نحن في حاله ازمه اداره الازمه
تتوجب علينا التركيز حول الحالات الطاريه
والطاريه وبالتالي
القطاعات التي تعمل في هذه المستشفيات
لحفظ ارواح الناس او جرح الحرب والحالات
الخطره من الحالات المزمنه التي تستقبلها
المسيطرات الطرفيه وشيف الطرفيه والتي
تمزع بالامان هو الحد الادنى يقدم الخدمه
على مستوى الطوارئ والعنايات المكثفه
والعنايات البسيطه والعنايه القلبيه
والعمليات الجراحيه وغسيل الكلى والولادات
المستعجله والامراض النساء والتوليد على
وجه العموم وخدمات الاطفال الطارئه ببدايه
الازمه كنا نتحدث عن نقص على مستوى
يعني المواد الاساسيه
والاسعافات الاوليه وكل الاجهزه الطبيه
الاساسيه هل اليوم هناك نقص وباي مجالات
ليس الحديث عن النفس ولكن الحديث عن
صعوبه في توصيل بعد المعينات للمستشفيات
التي تمتاز بالتردد العالي نسبه لوجودها
بالقرب من مناطق الاشتباك في وقف الان تم
استغلال فتره الهدنه لتوصيل المستهلكات
الى هذه المستشفيات وهي سبعه
حالات الاصابات اليها
الان المخزون بالنسبه للترددات
نحن مطمئنين حلو
دكتور محمد على مستوى
وخمسين حاله في 12 يوم هذا يعكس الكلام عن
النقص وليس نقص ولكن صعوبه في التوصيل
صعوبه في التوصيل ونحن نحاول بكافه الطرق
لتوصيل المستهلكات الى المستشفيات التردد
العالي من
العاصمه العاصمه اليوم منذ بدء الاشتباكات
تعاني من انقطاع الكهرباء نقص على مستوى
المياه وايضا حتى بالاتصالات ببعض الاحيان
الانقطاع المواد او الاساسيه او القطاعات
الاساسيه كيف تؤثر على عمل هذه المستشفيات
نعم هنالك من المستشفيات خارج الخدمه
او عندنا عدد اثنين مستشفى وكان الحديث
سابقا عن 103 مستشفى الثلاثه مستشفى التي
خرج عن الخدمه هي بسبب انقطاع الكهرباء
وجاري العمل على استعاده التيار الكهربائي
والمائي ولكن
اداره الازمه اداره الازمه نحن الان نوفر
الماء بطرق مختلفه ونوفر الوقود لعمل
المستشفيات المولدات عندنا الحلول البديله
التي حتى لا هل تستطيعون تحميل الكميات
اللازمه هناك شرح على مستوى الوقود بالقدر
الذي الان يوجد استقرار نوعا ما في عدد
كبير من المستشفيات في عدد كبير من
المستشفيات هنالك الحلول يعني الغرفه
المركزيه من مهامها انها تذليل العقبات
بالقدر الذي يسمح بتشغيل هذه
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه في السودان على هذه المداخله
تحذير اممي من كارثه صحيه في السودان 24
الف امراه سيلدن دون رعايه صحيه 50 الف
طفل يواجهون مخاطر حقيقيه
احدى وستون في المئه من المنشات الصحيه
مغلقه
16% من المرافق الصحيه تمارس عملها
المراكز المخصصه لمنع تفشي الاوبئه توقفت
عن العمل مع امكانيه وقوع اصابات بسبب شرب
مياه غير صالحه تسجيل 16 هجمه على مراكز
المنظمه الطبيه ومقتل ثمانيه اشخاص
الاستيلاء على مختبر طبي يثير مخاوف من
مخاطر بيولوجيه والتلاعب بالعينات
المخزونه
مشاهدينا اعود الى الزميل هاني صفيان من
ميناء جده الذي كان يرصد لنا طيله الساعات
الماضيه وصول الجاليه الصينيه عبر السفينه
الى الى قاعده
الى القاعده الملك فيصل في جده اعود اليك
هاني
نعم ليال اهلا بك طبعا هنا في قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه الجهه الاخرى في موقع اخر
وموقع مختلف ووصول سفينه جلاله الملك ابا
تابع للقوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه
التي تقل 200 او تم اجلام 200
وثلاثه اشخاص من بورتسودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه هنا في جده طبعا قبل
قليل شاهدنا نزول
اول عمليه اجراء الدفع الاولى من عمليه
الاجلاء الى هنا على الرصيف قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه ايضا في انتظار وصول المزيد
من
من وصلوا على متن هذه السفينه مراحل عده
يتم التاكد من اول اوله التاكد من سلامه
وصحه من هم علامتنا السفينه ومن هم تم
اجلاؤهم من قبل الصحه السعوديه وبعد ذلك
يتم التاكد من معلوماتهم وايضا
انتقالهم الى المرحله الاخرى عبر حافلات
خصصت وبعد ذلك الى مقر سكني الهند طبعا في
هذه الحاله ايضا او في هذه علامتنا هذه
السفينه ايضا عده جنسيات مختلفه سوف تتضح
لنا بعد قليل ولكن العدد
المتاكدين منه هو اكثر من
203 اشخاص هم ممن وصلوا على متن هذه
السفينه طبعا ما زلنا نرصد عمليات وصول
الاجلاء ولكن نشاهد فرحه الواصلين وفرحه
اول من وصل على هذا الرصيف ونشاهد هنا
فرحتهم لو التقت بعض الصور
للتعبير عن فرحتهم ويبدو انهم من الجنسيه
الاندونيسيه ولعل الجنسيه الاندونيسيه حتى
الان هي المستحوذه على اكبر
جاليه او اكبر عدد من الرعايه الذين يصلون
الى السعوديه او الى جده تحديدا اليوم
وصلوا اكثر من 500
واليوم نشاهد ايضا دفعه جديده ودفعه اخرى
تصل الى هنا عبرها السفينه جلاله الملك
ابها في انتظار المزيد من الوصول طبعا
ايضا من الواصلين في هذه اللحظات ايضا بعض
الرعايه الصين ونشاهد ايضا الملحق العسكري
الصيني نشاهد هنا في الجهه الاخرى نشاهد
ايضا رعايه الصينيين الذين وصلوا قبل قليل
وكذلك ايضا بعض الرعايه من السودان
وجنسيات مختلفه سوف تتضح لنا عند وصولنا
او عند نزولهم سوف تتضح لنا بشكل اكبر
طبعا الورود وكذلك الفرحه بالنسبه
للواصلين ليس فقط هم فرحتهم ولكن ايضا
فرحه من هم موجودون من القوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه اطفال وكبار وصغار من
الجنسين يصلون على متن هذه السفينه
السفينه جلاله الملك ابها واحده من السفن
التي
تقوم باجلاء عده رعايه من الجنسيات
المختلفه الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
هناك ثلاثه مواقع يتم اجلاء فيها رعايه
الجنسيات المختلفه في مدينه جده نتحدث عن
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه التي نتواجد
فيها ونتحدث ايضا عن قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه والتي ايضا
كانت العربيه ترصد وصول عمليه اجلاء لوصول
عدد من
الرعايه الكوريين وكذلك ايضا نتحدث عن
ميناء جدا الاسلامي والتي والذي كنا
نوافيكم فيه في بعض تفاصيله عند عمليه
اجلام الصينيين قبل او خلال الساعه
الماضيه في الجهه الاخرى على كل حال لهاني
سنعود اليك لمتابعه تغطيه وصول هذه كل
ركاب هذه السفينه شكرا لك نصفيان من قاعده
الملك فيصل في جده
مشاهدينا تنضم الينا من بيروت ايمان
طرابلس المتحدثه الرسميه للجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر للشرق الاوسط سابدا من يعني
الاوضاع الانسانيه داخل السودان كيف يمكن
وصف الاوضاع هناك خصوصا بان عمل المنظمات
الدوليه يعني اصبح محدود جدا نظرا
للاشتباكات الدائره
بالفعل عمل المنظمات
الدوليه هي هو جد محدود حاليا
الاخبار الاخيره التي وردتنا من زملائنا
في الميدان تشير ان هناك هدوء حظر حسب ما
لاحظناه في على مستوى الخرطوم من مما سمح
للسكان العريقين على امتداد ايام اليوم من
الخروج من اماكن اختبائهم او احتمائهم
للحصول على
الامدادات الاساسيه خاصه الغذاء والماء
وضعيه
المنشات الصحيه هي من بين
الاشياء التي تثير القلق فعليا باننا
اليوم نتحدث عن شبه انهيار لقطاع الخدمات
صحيه خاصه في الخرطوم بالنسبه للجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر نحن هدفنا
واولويتنا هو ان تتوفر كل ظروف اللازمه
بما فيها الضمانات الامنيه اللازمه
لمحاوله
هذا الوضع الذي اقل ما يمكن ان يقال عنه
ان ان يقال عنه الان هو انه خطر
هدفنا هو
ايصال المزيد عن المزيد من المساعدات خاصه
لدعم قطاع الصحه كيف يمكن ايصال المساعدات
اليوم خصوصا بان يعني معظم
الفرق ومعظم الكوادر الامميه تم اجلائها
وانسحبت من الداخل السوداني
بالنسبه للجنه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر نحن
لم نقم باجلاء اي من طواقمنا كل الطواقم
موجوده على عين المكان
الوضع وتازم الوضع الامني خلال الايام
الفارسه
جعلنا نعتمد اعاده نقل بعض التواقم
الموجوده من الخرطوم نحو اماكن اخرى ولكن
كل طواقمنا لا تزال موجوده على عين المكان
ونحن مستعدون للتحرك حاله ما نحصل على
الضمانات الامنيه اللازمه بما في الاحترام
لكل اطراف النزاع للهدنه اليوم هناك نزوح
كثيف لسكان الخرطوم نحو الجنوب السوداني
ونحو مناطق اخرى
خارج العاصمه ايضا يعني هناك نقطه اساسيه
اليوم حول هذا النزوح وهو المساعدات
الامميه بجنوب السودان هناك مناشدات بانه
اذا لم تتدخل ان كان الصليب الاحمر او
المنظمات الدوليه الاخرى فسيكون الوضع
كارثي لانه هي اصلا تعاني من نقص ونفس
يعني نفس المعاناه والشيء على الحدود وعلى
المناطق التي ينزح اليها السودانيين ما
للخطه التي ممكن يعني او التي ستبداون
بتطبيقها في الايام المقبله
الخطه هي ان نكون على قدره ان نتحرك وان
تتحرك في رقنه ميدانيا في اقرب وقت ممكن
لا يمكنني سيدتي ان اعلق فيما يخص
البرامج او الخطى الامميه ولكن بالنسبه
للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر بالطبع هذا
ليس للتقليل من من ضروره العمل على
السكان الذين سوف يلجاون الى النزوح خلال
الايام المقبله واخلال الايام الفارطه
كذلك ولكن اليوم اولوياتنا هي مسانده او
دعم القطاع الصحي في اقرب وقت ممكن خاصه
عبر تقديم
المساعدات والمواد الاغاثه الطبيه من
الضروره تحدثت تحدثت حضراتك عن مساله
النزوح من الضروره الاشاره بان السودان هو
كان بالفعل يعيش من من ازمه نجوح كانت
قائمه بالفعل نتحدث اليوم عن قرابه 4
مليون نازح موج ده في في مناطق مختلفه من
السودان بالاضافه الى حوالي مليون لاجئ
لاجئ الى السودان من الدول المجاوره التي
تعيش الاذاعات او صراعات يعني هي ما يحصل
الان من من موجات نزوح اضافيه هي اليوم
باختصار هي
بالفعل هو يعني
امر يسوع
حينما كان بالفعل هو سيء للغايه طيب هل
استطعتم ايصال اي من المساعدات الطبيه ام
ان الوقف التام والكلي لاطلاق النار هو
الشرط الاساسي
بالطبع الحصول على الضمانات الامنيه هو
الشرط الاساسي بالنسبه
للفاعلين الانسانيين بما فيهم اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر من الضروره ان يكون
تكون فرقنا على قدره من التحرر تحرك
والعمل ولكن هذا يجب ان يكون في اطار امن
يعني مع وجود ضمانات امنيه
اللازمه والتي يجب ان يقدمها طرفي النزاع
اليوم في السودان يعني ان يتفقوا وان
يتفقوا على احترام
[موسيقى]
الهدنه على خلفيه انسانيه هل تعرضتم لاي
مشاكل على مستوى
النهب على مستوى المضايقات على مستوى
اي مستويات امنيه او حتى مستويات اخرى
ليست هناك مضايقات ممكن ان اذكرها الان او
او تم ابلاغنا بها من زملائنا ميدانيا
ولكن اريد ان استغل هذه الفرصه لنؤكد
باننا نعيد نداءنا لطرفي النزاع بان هناك
ضروره بالالتزام بما ينص عليه القانون
الدولي الانساني هذا ليس خيار اليوم هو
مسؤوليه وهو واجب قانوني هذا
القانون الدولي الانساني وما يقتضيه من
حمايه لمصالح المدنيين والحياه والحياه
البشريه خاصه في اطار الاقتتال في مناطق
في مناطق يعني مكتظه بالسكان بالاضافه اذا
حمايه المنشات الاساسيه والبنيه التحتيه
الاساسيه
التي يعتمد عليها السكان بما فيها المنشات
الصحيه على كل حال يعني حتى بموضوع
القانون الدولي الانساني حتى بهذه النقطه
طرفي النزاع يتبادلان
البيانات والاتهامات بخرقه وبعدم احترامها
وبالتالي يعني على امل ان يلتزم الطرفين
بها شكرا لك ايمان طرابلسي المتحدثه
الرسميه للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
للشرق الاوسط على هذه المداخله
اسعار السلع تؤرق السودانيين حيث ازدادت
اسعار السلع الاساسيه الى اضعاف مما كانت
عليه قبل الحرب في ولايات عده في السودان
فلنتابعها
فوضى الاسعار
صدمه جديده على السودانيين تزيد الطين بله
نازحون هربوا الى مدن بعيده عن الخرطوم
الالاف هرب من المعارك الى شبح ارتفاع
الاسعار
ولايه الجزيره على بعد 160 كم من العاصمه
ارتفعت فيها الاسعار بنسبه 40 الى 100%
المواد التموينيه ان توفرت ووصلت اضعاف
السعر رغيف الخبز زاد عشره اضعاف مع موجات
النزوح غرف للايجار قدرت بمئه دولار
يباع الوقود على جنبات الطريق ب 80 دولارا
ارتفاع مرعب في الاسعار طال جميع ولايات
السودان
[موسيقى]
والان مشاهدينا الى موجز لاخر وابرز
الاخبار الدوليه
بعد اول محادثه هاتفيه بين الرئيس الصيني
شيت جينج مع نظيره الاوكراني
في اوكرانيا اعلنت الحكومه الصينيه انها
سترسل ممثلا خاصا عن بكين مسؤولا عن
الشؤون الاوروبيه الاسيويه الى اوكرانيا
ودول اخرى لاجراء محادثات معمقه مع جميع
الاطراف من اجل التوصل الى تسويه سياسيه
وقال مسؤول صيني الى محادثات جنبينج مع
موقف الصين الموضوعي والمحايد اذا الشؤون
الدوليه واحساسها بالمسؤوليه
قال الرئيس الاوكراني خلال مكالمه هاتفيه
مع الرئيس الصيني شيجن بينك ان لا سلام مع
روسيا على حساب التنازلات الاقليميه من
جانبيه قال الرئيس الصيني بان بلاده ستقوم
بارسال ممثل خاص عن الحكومه الصينيه الى
اوكرانيا لاجراء اتصال مع جميع اطراف
النزاع للتواصل الى حل بشان تسويه الازمه
السياسيه الاوكرانيه مؤكدا بان بلاده لن
تختار ان تكون متفرجا على الازمه
الاوكرانيه
اوضح مندوب روسيا لدى الامم المتحده بانه
لم يتم احراز تقدم حقيقي لحل القضايا التي
اثارتها موسكو بشان اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
عبر البحر الاسود والذي من المقرر ان
ينتهي العمل به الشهر المقبل مشيرا الى ان
روسيا لن توافق على التمديد ما لم يقم
الغرب بازاله العراقيل التي تعيق الصادرات
الروسيه من الحبوب والاسمده
افادت وزاره الروسيه الدفاع الروسيه بان
القوات البيلاروسيه يتم تدريبها في روسيا
لتشغيل انظمه صواريخ اسكندر بحسب الوزاره
فان الاطقم تتدرب في مكان غير محدد وهو
جنوبي روسيا منذ الثالث من الشهر الجاري
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه انه ليس من
المرجح التغلب على كل الخلافات مع الصين
الا انه توقع ان تحافظ بكين على
التزاماتها الدوليه فلنسمع لما قبلها
يجب ان نتعامل مع الصين عند الضروره وان
نكون واقعيين بشان التعامل مع الصين وهذا
يعني عدم التراجع عن مبدا واضح لا نتوقع
ان يتم التغلب على خلافاتنا مع الصين
بسرعه لكننا نتوقع ان تراعي الصين
القوانين والالتزامات التي تعهدت بها
اعلنت رئاسه الوزراء الفرنسيه اليزابيث في
بيان لها ان ان مشروع قانون الهجره الذي
طلب به الرئيس
الفرنسيتم تاجيله وذلك لعدم توفر التصويت
الكافي على نص القانون مما يؤجل الطرح
المفترض له واكدت بان بلادها تنظر الى هذه
المساله كاولويه مشيره الى ان فرنسا اعلنت
عن تعبئه 150 شرطي اضافه على الحدود
الايطاليه اعتبارا من الاسبوع المقبل
لمواجهه ضغوط الهجره المتزايده
اعلن مسؤول امريكيه بان الولايات المتحده
سترسل غوصا نوويه لتتوقف في كوريا
الجنوبيه في خطوه لتعزيز قدرات الردع في
مواجهه تهديدات كوريا الشماليه هذا واكد
المسؤول الامريكي انه سيتم الاعلان عن نشر
الغواصه المجهزه بصواريخ باليستيه ذات
القدرات النوويه في اطار اعلان واشنطن
الذي سيقره الرئيس الامريكي ونظيره الكوري
الجنوبي الذي يزور الولايات المتحده
تراجع رئيس جنوب افريقيا عن تعهده
بالانسحاب من المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
قبل اشهر من الموعد المقرر لاستضافه
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين المطلوب من
جانب المحكمه الدوليه بتهمه ارتكاب جرائم
الحرب وقالت الرئاسه ان جنوب افريقيا
ستبقى مع الدول الموقعه في المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه فماشيا مع قرار المؤتمر
الوطني الخامس والخمسين لحزب المؤتمر
الوطني الافريقي في ديسمبر لالغاء قرار
سابق بالانسحاب
مشاهدينا اختم هذه الساعه من التغطيه ولكن
طبعا التغطيه مستمره لاحداث السودان
وتداعياتها والان الى الزميل طاهر ملك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات